[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
cette édition est consacrée aujourd'hui
à la compagnie des clic théâtres qui
fêtent ses 20 ans alors c'est en effet
un 28 janvier
1993 que l'association des clic théâtres
voit le jour une compagnie de théâtre
pas tout à fait comme les autres puisque
l'essentiel de ces activités est axé
autour de l'improvisation théâtrale un
genre venu tout droit du Québec alors
parce qu'on n pas tous les jours 20 ans
nous recevons pour en parler ce soir une
partie de la joyeuse équipe et grande
famille que constitue des clic théâtrre
alors je commence avec vous Géraldine
Orquera pardon vous êtes
l'administratrice à côté de vous nurelia
King Louise vous êtes chargé du secteur
improvisation juste en face de vous
chona
vous êtes vous faites partie de l'équipe
des juniors de Trapp et à côté Stéphan
Guill bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes vous
comédien improvisateur alors on va tous
ensemble discuter autour de l'historique
de déclic et puis on va commencer
peut-être par une par une date donc
marquante qui est 1993 et donc je
m'adresse à vous Géraldine est-ce que
vous pouvez nous réexpliquer un petit
peu le le contexte de l'époque et
pourquoi donc la compagnie a été créée
alors pour la petite histoire
effectivement la compagnie a été crée en
1993 sous l'impulsion de Alain degis d
papis et Jean-Baptiste Chauvin donc qui
étit tous les deux cofondateur de la
compagnie mais on peut dire que DESC
théâtre ça existait déjà avant
puisqueeffectivement papy découvre
l'improvisation théâtrale le match
d'improvisation théâtrale dans le milieu
des années 80 sur SaintQuentin en
Yveline avec le Théâtre de l'Unité et et
dè le milier des années 80 il développe
des projets en milieu scolaire alors il
était à l'époque
voilà et puis puis aussi par la suite il
a travaillé à la mairie de trap il
développe des projets avec la c la
Merise et puis puis en réaction à un
moment parce que les projets ne peuvent
pas se poursuivre il décide de créer la
compagnie des clics théâtre pour
poursuivre les projets notamment en
milieu scolaire et puis pour pour créer
une compagnie alors justement quels
étaient les les objectifs de cette comp
bah les objectifs dès le départ ils
étaient le socle était déjà présent des
93 c'est-à-dire effectivement
mener des projets artistiques de pratiqu
artistiqu de création artistique autour
du match d'improvisation théâtrale euh
tout ça décliné dans un vaste travail de
création euh engagé et citoyen et une
vra voocation sociale culturelle
éducative oui voilà tout à fait euh et
donc donc le socle était déjà là et puis
après il y avait aussi le ferment d'une
vraie d'une compagnie théâtrale et donc
tout le travail de création puisquen
1993 on crée déjà le qu'int tête d'impro
qui un spectacle où le principe c'est
cinq comédiens qui improvisent sur les
thèmes des spectateurs et qu'aujourd'hui
ce ce ce spectacle continue de tourner
20 ans après tout à fait donc voilà donc
on va effectivement évoquer ensemble
tout ce qui fait la la success story de
de déclic parce que oui Déclic Théâtre
réussi alors on va le voir au fur à
mesure de cette émission norelia King
vous vous êtes un comment dire un pur
produit de la compagnie déclics vous
avez commencé en 93 au collège Gustave
donc à trappe vous avez évolué au fur et
à mesure dans la compagnie en étant
encadrant de d'atelierers et puis
embauché et enfin donc là aujourd'hui
responsable du du secteur
impro j'ai envie déjà de vous demander
vous qu'est-ce qui vous a amener à à
l'impro à intégrer ses ateliers de
manière très
simple j'ai revu papi qui était
éducateur sportif à l'époque que je
voyais avec les Éclaireurs de France je
l'ai revu dans enceinte de mon collège
en train de de mener dans cette fusse du
collège courbé des ateliers
d'improvisation et euh et du coup voilà
lui il m'a interpellé et puis je me suis
retrouvé un peu là par hasard au départ
et et j'ai très vite lâché le le Cano et
kayak pour pour intégrer les ateliers
d'impro après après ce qui est
intéressant pour moi ce qui ce qui m'a
fait rester dans les ateliers et puis
puis dans cette pratique c'est le le
côté bah tout d'un coup il y avait un
regard euh aussi du du du du collège et
des des des camarades qui qui étaient un
peu différents alors que bon je suis
passé de d'une espèce d'anonymat voilà
un côté et ça vous a permis aussi par
rapport aux autres en fait de de trouver
une place d'avoir ouais ouais c'est ça
tout à fait en fait il y a il y a eu il
y a eu un regard sur moi qui a été
différent de la part des professeurs des
camarades euh peut-être même voilà de
papis aussi et puis et puis et puis moi
ça m'a plu en tout cas voilà ça m'a plu
tout simplement alors çaçon on pratique
l'improvisation par plaisir avant tout
donc à partir du moment où on y est
c'est comme des gens qui font carrière
dans dans des dans un sport quelconque
ou ou quoi une fois qu'on y est et que
ça nous plaît on y reste et c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous vous y êtes
encore je suppose oui oui après j'ai
aussi eu des opportunités dans ma vie
qui ont fait que que que mon parcours a
été
possible je pense que la réussite de
Jamel entre autres a fait
que des
clic a pu aussi évoluer et a pu faire
des embauches au-delà de la mienne il y
a eu des embauches voilà de de de de
plusieurs personnes et et donc je
rentrai dans dans dans on voit
d'ailleurs quelques images d'archiv de
Jamel tout jeune hein dans la patin noir
des déclic effectivement alors alors
donc vous disiez ça vous a tellement plu
et tellement plu aussi en 99 vous êtes à
l'initiative d'un projet qui est les le
championnat intercollège de match
d'improvisation théâtrale
h c'est comme ça le dit
en je vous remercie c'était le défi du
jour sera la 15e édition cette année de
de ce format là du SI me effectivement
qui c'està-dire que donc moi je suis en
démaré avec 4 c'est collège aujourd'hui
on est à 10 participants 10 cèg parti
c'est l'évolution en fait du championnat
intercollège de trappp qui se déroulait
avec les trois collèges trapiste à
l'époque à l'époque de je vais dire
c'est ce qu'on app les
marmitons oui c'est ce qu'on appel les
on aujourd'hui on appelle ça le simth
euh le Sim ça veut dire championnat
intercollège m improvisation théâtrale
donc
voilà mais surtout c'était et comment
vous en êtes venu à créer un rendez-vous
annuel comme ça pour les collégiens moi
c'est rentré dans le cadre de mes
missions de de développer le match
d'improvisation dans les collèges et
pour nous c'était aussi avec la
communauté d'agglomération un intérêt
intercommunal interculturel entre les
villes de de de Saint-Quentin mixité de
la mixité et puis surtout tout et c'est
ce qui fait que ça perdure et que ça
évolue aujourd'hui c'est c'est la
dimension à faire rencontrer euh des
jeunes dans dans dans une jûte qui peut
être considérée comme sportive par son
aspect par l'aspect championnat mais
dans une joutte en tout cas où les où où
les codes sont des rapports humains de
de communication de de voilà et puis et
puis artistique et tout d'un coup on se
retrouve avec effectivement
[Musique]
un mélange un mélange qui se fait dans
la patinoire et puis après des parcours
de comédiens qui commencent là et qui
vont qui vont au-delà avec avec des
comédiens de de ça on va y revenir là je
vais laisser la parle on peut pas tout
dire maintenant
stphie
entend en tant que comédien
improvisateur vous avez vous
l'expérience aussi bah des des 20 ans
puisque vous y étiez en
93 alors justement qu'est-ce qui queles
sont les les qualités les bonnes
qualités qui qu'il faut avoir pour être
un improvisateur alors en fait j'ai
demandé j'ai demandé à shona tout à
l'heure parce que je savais pas trop
moi-même et elle m'a dit il faut avoir
de l'imagination donc ça c'est quand
même assez importantimagination pour
toiination c'est c'est une grande partie
de l'impro surtout d'accord est-ce qu'
il y a d'autres choses d'autres clés qui
sont sont important de H je pense qu' y
a quelque chose qui est assez important
c'est d'avoir une assez vaste culture
générale forcément une culture générale
littéraire ou au son strict du terme
faut pas forcément connaître tous les
auteurs classiques de théâtre et cetera
mais oui être ouvert à à ce qui se passe
dans dans le monde quoi connare un petit
peu avoir des références et ça aide
beaucoup en fait finalement pour avoir
des espèces d'images mentales de
différentes possibilités de situation
parce qu'il faut se représenter
effectivement mentalement les choses
pour pouvoir lesou par exemple je vous
demande de me faire une improvisation à
la manière de la science fiction
aurellia je non voilà parce que vous
regardez pas de film de science-fiction
si pourtant si mais il y en a tellement
que je ne sais pas vers lequel c'est un
peu ça que d'avoir suffisamment de
références culturelles pour pouvoir
s'adapter à différents type de jeu
possible et ça permet d'être à l'aise
dans le jeu après effectivement faut
avoir aussi de l'imagination il faut
être à l'écoute des autres une ouverture
d'esprit ah mon Dieu non mais c'est bon
ça va il a des trucs qu' vaut mieux pas
regarder voilà s'il vous plaît pouvez
enlever cette
cette bon je savais que c'était pas très
gentil de votre parents on avait dit pas
les vieilles images dit équité à chacun
on essaie de retrouver des Archiv était
beau à l'époque mais Géraldine on en a
pas d'image d'archives alors on a
retrouvé cette image Géraldine quand tu
avais 12 ans tu sortais de chez le
dentiste avec tes bagues comment estu au
courant e oui tu vois on sait tout alors
l'improvisation doncêelle c'est un moyen
de s'exprimer on l'a dit par le langage
par le MIM également donc en fonction
des des ressources imaginaires que que
l'on peut avoir donc certains comme
Jamel Debou sopia Haram marnaud de Samè
Issa dbia pour ne citer que voilà là ont
fait leur premier pas dans la patinoire
de Déclic Théâtre et sont devenus des
comédiens professionnels reconnus du
grand public alors on va écouter
justement Issa dumbia et Jamel de Bou
que l'on a rencontré plusieurs fois mais
là en l'occurrence il nous explique en
quoi l'impro leur a apporté des clés
dans leur parcours
professionnel aujourd'hui je me base
beaucoup sur des textes mais quand il y
a certains certains réalisateurs qui qui
nous disent bah si tu as de nouvelles
propositions pour ton personnage vas-y
bah c'est une source de proposition
l'improvisation théâtrale puisque j'ai
fait des films où j'ai improviser des
scènes qui sont restées à l'image donc
du coup quand on les voit au cinéma on
se dit que c'est écrit mais en fait ça
vient de l'improvisation et ben c'est
pour ça que Déclic Théâtre m'a beaucoup
beaucoup apporté et j'y suis toujours la
compagnie je suis là la preuve à chaque
événement j'essaie d'être présent écez
monsieur l'arbitre apparemment vous
l'avez pas
changé
ouj énervé pour
rien j'ai pensé que ça pourrait amuser
le
public en
ridicule merci
capitaine la leçon que j'ai retenu
l'écoute j'is dire exactement la même
chose donc on est sur la même longueur
d'
vent écoute c'est la valeur principale
écouter l'autre pour pouvoir créer avec
lui sinon c'est pas
possible cont que Jam n'oublie pas ça
mais mais ça me sert encore aujourd'hui
quand quand je tournais avec Fernando
mer il y a pas longtemps et et je te
jure que c'est ces outils qu' m filé en
impro qui qui me servent encore
aujourd'hui je quand je ne sais pas je
j'écoute et et
bizarrement bizarrement je je je finis
par savoir alors voilà pour Jamel c'est
l'écoute c'est une des clés voilàte oui
euh noreling vous qui suivez ces jeunes
depuis 20 ans est-ce que selon vous en
depuis 20 ans depuis de nombreuses une
dizaine d'années quinzaine
d'années une bonne dizaine d'années vous
avez vu l'évolution de de ces jeunes et
leur rentrer dans l'impro est-ce que
est-ce que ça a changé est-ce qu'il y a
des choses le leur motivation de départ
ont changé ou pas peut-être justement la
la notoriété de déclic le ce rêve d'un
destin comme Jamel comme comme Arnaud sa
mère par exemple bah peut-être peut-être
qu'il y en a qui viennent avec voilà je
pense qu'ils sont une minorité qui
viennent avec voilà des des des a priori
de de réussite et de et de carrière
fulgurante à la Jamel à de sa mère ou
quoi simplement quand ils arrivent dans
nos ateliers ils se rendent vite compte
que le diapason il est le même pour tout
le monde que que les bonnes valeurs
c'est celle de l'écoute comme on vient
de le dire c'est pas nécessairement que
le talent mais bon c'est l'écoute c'est
le travail sur soi le travail avec
l'autre mine de rien l'assiduit ou genre
de chos qui permettent de de bien
fonctionner avec avec une personne
et après est ce que ça a
changé je pense que ça a changé parce
qu'il y a plus d'exemples mais bon
foncièrement comme je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure on arrive on s'y sent bien on
a envie d'y rester aussi donc à partir
du moment où où où nous on permet
l'accueil on voit d'ailleurs sopia alors
sopia RAM de sa mère il y a donc
quelques années ouais on citer d'autres
pour leur faire plaisir cédricin Jérémy
Jourdan Virginie griten il y en a plein
plein de copains là ch à toi par exemple
qu'est-ce que ça t'importe qu'est-ce que
ça t'apporte l'impro au quotidien
peut-être ça fait 7 ans que tu en fais
on va juste repréciser tu as 15 ans tu
es chez les juniors voilà peut-être
est-ce qu'à l'école ou dans ta vie
sociale avec tes amis qu'est-ce que ça
t'apporte bah ça importe surtout bah tu
peux parler très très très facilement
avec les autres tu tu peux impr iser sur
n'importe quoi sur n'importe qui et en
fait ça apporte bah des
connaissances des découverte aussi et ça
apporte une famille en fait parce que
déclic c'est vraiment une famille ça
c'est une grande famille c'est une
grande famille on se connaît tous et du
coup alors on parle de on parle de
famille alors justement cette famille va
être réunie parce que pour fêter cet
anniversaire comme il se doit un
fiestacle oui vous avez bien entendu un
fiestacle est organisé samedi à la
Merise alors papy et Mélanie l moine
nous en parl au micro de Nicolas
gervey déc théâtre à 20 ans non si si
toend parce que il y a deux trucs deux
trucs à savoir premier truc numéro 1
papi s'en va papi s'en
vaattend ttoi il s'en va c'est Mélanie
Lemine Geraldine orkerera qui vont
reprendre le flambeau ça c'est la chose
numéro 1 info numéro 1 info numéro 2
l'info la numéro 2 qui arrive là qui est
maintenant c'est que le 12 octobre le 12
octobre et ben il y a un grand fiestacle
un truc de fou pour fêter les 20 ans de
la compagnie un grand si tu es toi non
c'est là regarde pas
maintenant un fiestacle le fiestacle
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est une c'est un
concept inventé ici même à la marmite
euh tout à fait qui qui reprend tout
simplement la fiesta et le spectacle
c'est un spectacle dans lequel on fait
la fiesta il a a 20 ans maintenant que
cette compagnie existe donc on s'est dit
qu'il fallait marquer le
coup on l'a vraiment conçu comme un
comme un cadeau tous les talents qui ont
traversé des clics plus ou moins
longtemps pour différentes raisons pour
différentes choses on essae voilà de de
de mutualiser tous ces talents là pour
offrir un cadeau nou pas que tu un
homosexuel ta mère ta mère est
homosexuelle c'était quand même une
sacré un sacré challenge de de préparer
cette soirée parce qu'effectivement euh
des clipcat une compagnie dans laquelle
il y a beaucoup de choses il y a
beaucoup d'activités il y a beaucoup de
savoir-faire il y a beaucoup de d'envie
aussi et il y avait en plus l'envie de
surprendre donc il fallait réussir à
faire un truc avec tout ce qu'on sait
faire et en plus des trucs nouveaux donc
on sait faire du masque on sait faire de
l'impro on sait faire des pièces de
théâtre on sait faire de l'humour aussi
donc donc voilà c'est c'est comment ce
ce ce patchwork artistique d'une densité
incroyable puisse se retrouver dans une
seule soirée et puis c'est une
préparation assez collégiale c'està-dire
queil y a quand
même un paquet de gens qui qui vont
mettre la main à la patte pour que pour
que ça se passe bien je pense qu'il un
plaisir pour beaucoup à à redonner dans
cette soirée quelque chose à cette
compagnie qui les a qui qui a toujours
été là en fait pour eux ok la vieillé
est venu frapper à ta porte qu'est-ce
que tu lui as mis sur la
tête un
chapau coup coup coup ça va pas du tout
pas du tout les enfants ça va pas du la
Merise a accompagné aussi de enfin même
si on était là avant son
ouverture accompagneré aussi les
tempsforts de de de la compagnie li
strata où effectivement tous les deux
nous avons nous avons joué euh entre
autres le dernier spectacle de théâtre
qu' a fait là-bas un certain nombre
quand même de matchs d'impro de final de
de de trophées voilà donc effectivement
C cette salle est lié aussi à notre
histoire effectivement il y a quelques
têtes d'affiche et j'ai presque envie de
dire j'ai presque pas envie de de les de
les nommer là parce que les gens les
connaissent ils connaissent leur
parcours et j'aimerais aussi nommer tous
ces enfants tous ces jeunes qui qui sont
des milliers à être passés depuis 20 ans
par par cette compagnie il y aura
effectivement des têtes d'affiche comme
on dit aujourd'hui euh qui sont sortis
de là mais mais j'ai pas envie de les
nommer là parce que j'ai envie que ça
soit la fête de déclic avant tout et de
et de tous e c'était dur hein c'était
dur 2 minutes c'est pour ça de rentré
mais je
P j'ai perdu j'ai perdu
les je pense ça va renir vite j'ai
profité je crois de de ces 20 ans c'est
un moment important pour moi aussi de
réfléchir sur mon parcours dans cette
compagnie que j'ai créé que j'ai
accompagné et euh je me suis dit que
c'était le moment de passer la main de
faire une transition que de laisser la
possibilité à cette compagnie de se
réinventer de de d'explorer nouvell
nouveaux chemins et c'est vrai que bah
dans ma tête c'est
imposé le le nom de de Mélanie le
moine parce que c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui accompagner cette compagnie et qui
sera je crois avec Géraldine et toute
l'équipe de déque théâtre euh je pars je
pars de la compagnie de ce poste de
directeur artistique ça veut pas dire
que j'aimeris pas taper le bœuf avec les
copains mais je pars de la compagnie en
en étant serein et en étant vraiment
enthousiaste à savoir qu' que que voilà
que que il y a des gens qui vont prendre
sabre le corps et là Mélanie je lui fais
entièrement confiance avec l'équipe de
de s'amuser et de se faire plaisir à
faire vivre encore longtemps cette
compagnie ensuite vous viendrez prendre
la petite copie la voyez là là là c'est
mais ça ne fait pas mal qu tout pass là
tout pass là effectivement moi je
travaille à déclic maintenant depuis un
peu plus de 10 ans donc j'ai accompagné
papi et puis tous les autres dans des
projets très différents puce que j'ai
donné des ateliers j'ai fait des matchs
j'ai fait des spectacles d'impro ce qui
est certain c'est que moi j'ai une
culture vraiment très théâtrale et que
donc j'ai envie moi de de mettre du
théâtre encore plus qu'il y en a déjà de
d'essayer peut-être de de pousser un peu
plus loin tous les tous les projet
vraiment de scène avec les acteurs
professionnels avec les artistes qui qui
sont dans la compagnie ah 16 qu'est-ce
qui se
passe hein qu'est-ce que c'est C c'est
quoi C c'est l' du
[Applaudissements]
goûter je ne vais pas disparaître le 12
octobre euh non non je je je continue
j'ai plusieurs axes de recherche
artistique que je veux continuer à
développer pour se faire j'ai
effectivement créer une une société de
production qui s'appelle AD2 production
avec Albert drandov dans
l'accompagnement artistique a 6i mois de
jeunes humoristes et tout c'est vrai que
ça devenait difficilement compatible
avec ce gros travail qu'il y a à faire
là euh voilà et aussi toute la partie de
de sculpteur que que parce que quand je
serai grand ch sculpteur Nicolas c'est
ça qu'il faut savoir donc j'ai aussi
aussi cette envie de de garder du temps
pour pour cheminer sur
cette cette pratique artistique que que
que je redécouvre qui a une vieille
envie de de gamin que je veux réaliser
et voilà donc le gros fiestacle de
Déclic Théâtre à la meurise c'est le 12
octobre à vous les studios dio studio
Studio à vous à vous aurellia et puis
bonjour
Géraldine
merci Nicolas donc tout le monde vous
embrasse
ici du
plateau alors on ti
remercier nos monteurs donc Pascal
Joseph et Xavier Jalin qui ont donc
ressorti des archives certaines datant
de 95 les images vous les avez vu j'ai
entendu vous étiez content de revoir
certaines d'entre elles alors Géraldine
papy donc passe la main pour la partie
direction artistique à Mélanie Lemoin
donc c'est ce qu'il nous disait par
ailleurs cette coirection finalement
elle existait déjà avec vous sur la
partie donc vous sur l'administration
lui c'est avant sur la direction
artistique aujourd'hui ça sera Mélanie
lomine pourquoi cette volonté de le
mettre en lumière maintenant on a trouvé
effectivement la codirection elle
existait depuis plusieurs années
maintenant donc mais on a trouvé ça
intéressant de le mettre en lumière
parce que pour faire vivre pour montrer
que pour faire vivre une structure
culturelle une compagnie de spectacle
vivant il y a besoin il y a une alliance
incontournable celle de d'une part des
AR et d'autre part des professionnels de
métier de la culture qui sont compétents
en production gestion fiscalité et
cetera comm uneentreprise quoi voilà et
et quand je dis des artistes et des
professionnels c'est au-delà de Mélanie
et de moi-même c'est toute une équipe
toute voilà d'équip th c'est un
formidable travail d'équipe donc on
trouvait ça intéressant de mettre en
lumière cette cette alliance parce que
effectivement on a de véritables
entreprises à gérer maintenant et que et
que l'un ne va pas sans l'autre voilà et
puis en même temps bah deux cirectrices
ça ça DOP les les
statistiques concernant le nombre de
femmes qui qui dirige les structures
culturelles donc donc voilà on en
profite exactement alors pour la partie
la vocation découvreur de talent alors
du coup quel sera le le devenir de de
déclic ça ça reste un talent de papi
donc donc effectivement il va partir
avec cette avec ce dossier avec cette
valise sous le sous le bras et
effectivement dans le cadre de ces
nouvelles activités et de ce de C
société de production à des deux il
continuera il poursuivra ce travail mais
effectivement ça va
sortir de déclip théâatre enfin après de
toutère il restera un lien avec Papi il
continuera d'être comédien voilà c'est
on va pas couper si je peux me permettre
de là-dessus euh moi je pense que si
papi a découvert des talents aussi à
trrappe c'est parce que ces talentsl on
sont passés par les ateliers de match
d'improvisation de décc rév par part
avec cette valise de découvr le talent
les talents les découvrira ils vont pas
sortir de terre où ils seront donc ils
seront peut-être dans les ateliier de
peut-être que SHON oui oui dans les
juniors équipe dans laquelle shona
rentre il y a eu sur 20 ans il y a eu
une centaine de jeunes qui sont qui se
sont succédés il y a 30 % de ces jeunes
qui sont aujourd'hui professionnels du
spectacle artistes ou technicien ça
n'est pas la vocation de Déclic Théâtre
mais force est de constater que que
c'est un trempin thâre cette cette
famille cette voilà c'est c'est
vraiment alors pour pour remercier papi
de son de son travail durant 20 ans on a
retrouvé un petit message que lui a
adressé Jamel il y a quelques années on
regarde il faut que tu saches que je
t'aime papi que tu es pour
moi l'êre illustre je te dois tout papi
tu es mon
gourou si je peux peut te rendre service
n'hésite pas euh comment te
dire je
taime voilà Jamel jeune effectivement
mais en tout cas merci à tous les quatre
d'être venus sur le plateau du kiosque
pour nous parler et oui de cet
anniversaire minut et ben ça fait 26
minutes mais alors bah on se quitte pas
très longtemps parce qu'on va se
retrouver samedi c'està dire qu'on a pas
tout à fait 20 ans peut-être voilà
peut-être qu'on bientôt mais en tout cas
on se retrouve samedi donc le 12 octobre
samedi
je ser là je vais suivre avec vous ce
grand fiestacle voilà merci à vous à
vous quatre donc notre édition est à
présent terminé merci de nous avoir
suivi sur TVfil moi je vous retrouve
mercredi prochain à 18h30 en direct
d'ici là à
[Musique]
bientôt